good afternoon and welcome to
the overview and scrutiny committee um
which is live streamed on youtube i will
do a roll call now to confirm the
members of the committee in attendance
councillor austin present
councillor bulovant
[Music]
could you actually indicate by speaking
uh you have your microphone i couldn't i
could not mute it but it's now
okay mute it's on here yes thank you
cancel the doors
yes i'm here councillor evans
yes chancellor hayes
president councillor hook gordon
councillor morgan president councillor
nuttall president councillor parker khan
president councillor linda pedreck
present councillor
swain
moving on to the first item on the
agenda
uh apologies which we now have uh
councillor two
uh the second item appointment of chair
please could um we have nominations can
i
nominate this uh gordon hook sarah can i
nominate um
councillor bulwant as uh chair of ons
ii and andy swain as vice chair
of ons too
thank you councillor we'll do the
election of the chair first we
um it's on the agenda of separate items
so i do need to take them a separate
item so
i've got a proposal for uh councillor
phil bullivan as chair uh from gordon
hook
seconded by uh councillor morgan do i
have any other nominations
with that in mind i'll go to the roll
call to vote for uh
councillor bulevan as chair
councillor austin four
councillor bullevant
[Music]
four councillor cox
[Music]
hook or councillor
morgan councillor nuttall
or councillor parker khan
poor councillor pedrick
[Music]
that's la swain four
that's carried i'll hand over to you now
uh
councillor bulovan thank you very much
and thank you everybody for your votes
for
me as chad uh some of the
basic details can you please make sure
all your microphones are muted and when
you're not speaking
so that we can avoid any background
noise levels
please keep any points short and don't
interrupt when somebody is speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic blue hand and wait to be
called
when it comes to the vote a democratic
services officer will read out the
members names
would remember what members please say
if they are voting for against or
abstaining
we'll have a break at a convenient time
for some 90 minutes into the meeting if
it is required
if members lose their internet
connection the meeting will be paused
for a few minutes to allow the members
to rejoin okay so can we move on then
for the next item which is the election
of a vice chair
i'd like to know that council randy
we have a nomination for councillor andy
swain i am happy to second that as a
uh i would like to second that
thank you we have a number of seconders
for that are there any other nominations
please for vice chairs
i'm not receiving any other nominations
for vice chair can we therefore go to
the vote on
uh on that please sarah okay i'll take
very cool councillor austin
councillor austin
[Music]
oh councillor hook four
councillor morgan councillor nuttel
councillor parker khan councillor
pedrick councillor
[Music]
[Music]
congratulations cows the swade and
welcome on board as vc
thank you very much well as we move on
now please
um are there any declarations of
interest please
i'm receiving no indication of any
direct uh people with
interest to declare so you move on to
item five please are there any public
questions
i have no indication of any public
questions
no i haven't had any okay thank you
move on to then to item six on the
agenda
are there any counselor questions i have
no
written questions coming to me are there
any um and we're gonna sleep no
no no received okay
everybody to pages five to eight of the
report which is the work
program are there any questions or
comments about the work
programme yes please
gordon thank you the table yours uh well
i i look
in vain for any mention of the car park
working
party working group working whatever and
i wondered whether that was still
functioning
whether it was um something we're likely
to have a report
about and from and you know exactly
where we are with that one please
uh it's certainly not on our agenda i
mean which portfolio
holder does that come under normally
well it's neil blaney car parks and uh
tanya looks after him yeah which
portfolio holder is the responsible
person
well it's not uh it's not sport
recreational culture and it's not
planning as such
i imagine it's it's corporate resources
i suppose
council councillors all chad would would
you like me to comment at all
if you wouldn't mind please sarah yep um
oh
i i believe that comes under um economy
um but i will um we'll check that and
we'll make sure that
um whichever ons that it gets added to
the work program
so i'll speak to the relevant portfolio
holder and the
uh slt sorry senior leadership team lead
thanks very much sir can i through you
chair can i just ask if
if that that committee has sort of been
bubbling along for a long time
and is it still in existence is
is the membership still the same does it
need a new membership does it need
any action with respect and i think
um with the new structures it's up to
the individual whichever group it goes
into and i'm definitely happy he comes
into os2
but whichever group will establish a uh
a group within itself to look at it i
can't if it if it's economy it'll be in
group one
oh yeah nina's
a portfolio holder for that and she's
actually here
so i don't know if you want nina to
comment on that well nina's not one of
the portfolios that we have a
uh coverage of in this group so we'll
leave it to sarah as you get a clarity
okay
and take you to the appropriate group
can i
for the first time just before lockdown
and
council park khan's on it as well um we
have been planning quite
quite a list of things but obviously
with kobe 19
that got put to the wayside tonya not so
long ago put round an email to talk
about
uh us convening a meeting at some point
but we haven't got around to it since i
think they've been kind of overwhelmed
to be honest
i think i know there's a lot of work
going on it's the question of where
the most appropriate place for that uh
meeting to be convened and let's
leave it to sarah to establish which
group it should go under and then
certainly it should be added to the
agenda of the appropriate
uh committee until we get that clarified
i think that's
that's as far as we ought to go here
today
uh are there any other questions about
the work program
you'll note by the way under the
existing tax
task and finish groups we have uh
three groups listed down there one is
relative to the cultural quarter
now with uh gut coming under this
committee the group structure looking at
that encompasses
by invitation every councillor with a
seat
within newton abbott uh it relates
currently to newton abbott so all
councillors are invited
and will be taking part in that meeting
um
gordon was because of his position
as a county councillor also invited but
now he's part of the
uh ernest team that that role
still continue for him um
jackie hook he's still a county
counselor so by invitation she is also
part of that group
and we've also invited three members of
the town council to join the group as
well and that those three members of the
mayor
which is uh richard jenks the tan clerk
um phil roe and sally henley the town
center manager to join the group so we
can have a
roundtable discussion about how we
should be moving forward with the ideas
there
similarly there is a group set up to
look at employment sites
and then the members of that group
i will with your agreement write to them
and reconfirm that that group should
continue to work
and the idea there is that we follow
that work program through to recommend
actions to the executive about how we
can bring forward more
employment sites there is a much larger
group
a separate one which is associated with
kobe 19 and the
analysis as we move forward that has not
yet been refined or
detailed there were three groups of
totaling 18 members
looking at town or urban
rural and coastal communities and
establishing their views
we need further clarification on how
that will be working but that is
is an urgent project and will be taken
up after this meeting
are there any other issues coming
through from the work program
i'm seeing nothing so can we move on
then with the
um with agenda if they're okay with that
okay moving on then to item eight can i
invite
um gary taylor as executive holder for
uh planning
to give us an update on his department
please
gary thank you very much uh uh chair
uh and congratulations on on return
returning to the chair of uh overview
and scrutiny committee uh
too thank you uh mr chairman thank you
for inviting me to make this
presentation on
planning today to members of the
overview and scrutiny committee too
as members well i'm sure know this
presentation is set up against
a backdrop not only of global
uncertainty due to covert 19
about which more later but also one of
potential upheaval to our planning
system
from development management which
provides the end-to-end planning
application
process we are familiar with through to
spatial planning and delivery
where a regularly reviewed 20-year local
plan
sits at the heart of sustainable and
strategic growth
little looks set to remain as before
the most controversial proposal change
as many see it will be
to the standard formula for housing need
this change would see a rise in the
government's requirement for team bridge
from an annual figure
currently of 760 to a new requirement of
over twice that amount 1532 houses a
year
by way of a comparison south hams would
have an even greater potential target to
meet
an increase of 115 while west devon is
at the bottom of the new table with the
14
reduction devon wide
the calculation is expected to deliver
an additional 49
increase almost 8 000 units
annually in total or a new town the size
of newton abbott
every 18 months consultation on the
proposed changes to the current planning
system including those regarding
permitted development affordable housing
delivery and the housing number formula
closes on the first of october while the
government's white paper setting out its
vision
for what may follow in planning for the
future
closes later on the 29th of october
as noted in the slides today a review of
these planning reforms
and the housing number calculation will
be held later this week
at the local plan working group meeting
on thursday
at 2 pm none group members are also
invited to the meeting where responses
to both consultations will be considered
returning to kobe 19 while even the best
planners crystal ball
or mathematicians algorithm cannot
predict exactly what will happen and
when
we can at least take stock from the
evidence of the last
six months while continuing to make
medium to long term plans for the future
on the balance of all probability even
after considering today's announcement
encouraging us all
to continue to work from home in looking
back at what has happened during
lockdown
while key workers including many in
construction
were initially allowed to continue to
work on site
supplies of materials quickly became the
pinch point
and while ppe and blue rolls
hit the national headlines building
projects large and small were also beset
with supply chain issues
with variously bricks blocks sand and
cement
and matte white paint in short supply
sites closed housing delivery ground to
a halt
with the result that very few homes and
sadly no affordable homes
were delivered in this financial year's
first quarter
post lockdown sites have reopened and
with supply chains becoming replenished
skilled labour and associated services
such as
architects and structural engineers have
fast become the constraint
i can advise that causing calls and
inquiries to devon building control
also have increased during this period
however physical site visits have in
many circumstances has been replaced by
photographic evidence
of works undertaken with the same modus
operandi
also employed by team bridge planning
officers
if we turn to slide 11 our most recent
monthly development management
performance measures for planning
applications and inquiries
reflect this increase in activity with
an output gap
demonstrating a growing need to backfill
posts
that had become vacant during the year
despite the efficiencies of a reduction
in the proportion of site visits
i'm very pleased to report therefore the
recent successes noted in recruitment
and with one vacancy only remaining i
would expect our officers soon to be
holding the line on
outstanding applications and inquiries
slide 10 gives the weekly applications
received figures from
2019 20 which show the summer bounce
back in more detail
while the approved applications and
appeals allowed graph
indicates a steady percentage rating on
approvals
and a noticeable dip in appeal wins
paying back appeal costs to a four
figure sum
other national indicators planning
applications approved within guideline
time frames
also shown show good all-round
performance
continuing slide nine
presents some of the wider development
management performance
picture for 2019-20
so we have 1 118 decisions
19 tpos 411 enforcement complaints
closed and a number of uh
gains from s106 and still liability
as i pointed out earlier costs awards
awarded against us in planning appeals
amounted to 9420 pounds
looking further ahead with a stamp duty
holiday for homes under half a million
pounds
until march the 31st next year
the return to house building would seem
set to continue for the remainder of
this council year
which will help underpin our housing
delivery housing delivery quota
and keep us ahead of a five-year land
supply for the immediate future
hitting these targets are important in
fending off unwarranted development
and planning by appeal but adequate
delivery can only be maintained
as long as identified allocations
windfall sites
the necessary infrastructure and of
course planning permissions
continue to come forward at pace if we
now move to slide
seven this carries much of the past
year's headlines and development news on
major schemes in and around newton
abbott and to the southwest of exeter
at mapford including on housing supply
that we ended the year with a strong
housing land supply number at 7.1 years
despite a weaker delivery rate of 460
homes
noting also that the housing target now
has written risen from the 620 per year
originally set in the local plan in 2014
to the 760 houses per year as currently
defined
through the government standard method
our major infrastructure that planning
permission has been granted for the a382
corridor improvements
including both the hout barton link and
jetty marsh link
with works commenced on phase one of the
a382
improvements assisted through over five
million pounds of sale
funding and two million pounds from
related s106 contributions
and that an agreement of 55 million
pounds of forward funding support via
homes england for infrastructure through
the housing infrastructure fund
has been completed for the south west of
exeter medford site
with planning permission also for an all
through school campus
slide eight looks at a range of other
headlines from the last 12 months
each one worthy of a much longer
presentation than time
allows today the duelist station section
of the sea
wall was of course approved in august
one of the most costly and complicated
schemes ever to be decided
in team bridge a binary choice
between the preservation or obliteration
of historic structures in the cause of
rail resilience
the decision will have been eased
through the inclusion of a
fully accessible down platform with lift
together with a raft of mitigation
measures and design
improvements concluded over a very short
period of time
by our case officer network rails should
also
be credited to responding to local
concerns on material finishes and
viewing areas which i hope will help
retain the area's
wow factor once completed also endorlish
has come a further investment in
infrastructure via homes england with
some 4.9 million of housing
infrastructure funding going towards a
link road and bridge
this upfront investment has been
necessary to allow three sites
in separate ownerships to benefit from
direct access to the a379
at the eighth at the sainsbury's
roundabout to the north of the town
the first of these sites to gain
permission is scheduled also to deliver
employment land which is to be welcomed
as provision
is below target in delivery tone terms
as noted here
and of course by your good self earlier
in the meeting
two neighborhood development plans have
been adopted this year
both kenton and chudley neighbourhood
plans were made
in march with planning applications now
being judged against these development
plans by teambridge in future planning
decisions
neighbourhood plans maximize local
income from the community infrastructure
with an increase from 15 to 25 percent
of the levy going to the respective
parishes
despite a current freeze preventing us
from recruiting for the vacant position
of neighbourhood planning officer
we do remain committed to support the
preparation of neighborhood plans
elsewhere to give communities more
control over development in their
localities
as per our continuing t10 ambition
the last headlight head line head
highlight
on slide seven is a reminder of the
fantastic amount of work
that has been done towards part one of
the 2020 to 2040 local plan
by officers the local plan working group
local stakeholders and the public
a huge virtual mailbag of responses
received over a consultation period
extended to some
16 weeks will now inform policies
helping to counter climate change
benefit nature and improve the living
and building
environment through quality place making
part one of the local plan of course
details how
development takes place whereas slide
12 starts us on the journey
to where development takes place looking
in the first instance
of strategic development and the future
of joint planning
as members will know in august
teambridge voted to go forward with the
three other guest
local planning authorities exeter city
council
and mid devon and east devon district
councils with a consultation round on
proposed
strategic sites in the greater exodus
exeter
area as noted in the slide the more
recent withdrawal by east devon
will sadly mean an s end to guess
as a statutory plan but not to joint
planning
we believe cooperation with other local
authorities
despite what it may say in the
government's most recent uh
information will
will continue to provide the best
opportunities for leveraging
investment for major infrastructure
projects such as new roads and stations
and for step change built environment
initiatives such as garden communities
all four local planning authorities are
now expecting to accelerate their
individual local plan
timetables but to continue to work in
parallel to prepare a non-statutory area
plan or prospectus
which will inform and complement their
own local plans
slide 13 looks specifically at newton
abbott
which has been chosen as one of the 49
garden communities
in the country after much good work
behind the scenes by our officers
a necessarily busy slide with lots going
on including 11
super projects at the heart of the
initiative at
super projects at the heart of the and
at the heart of the
initiative is the focus on a low-carbon
future
involving sustainable transport green
infrastructure corridors
and where possible brown and wherever
possible brownfield
redevelopment widespread community
engagement is expected to help establish
a vision for newtonia as a whole as well
as for new and existing neighborhoods
to think outside of the box of a car
dependent society
is a recent quote i heard about garden
communities
and i hope this is an in is this is
an initiative we would all wish to
support
slide 14 covers the key events and
decisions on the immediate horizon
and our priorities going forward
having just talked about green
infrastructure corridors it is good to
note that progress on the final route of
the teen estuary trail
is being made in conjunction with local
landowners as a keen cyclist myself
i look forward to the day it could open
although i may need electrical
assistance to climb the hill out of
timmouth
it is good to see green infrastructure
at the south west of exeter countryside
between mapford and exminister also
coming forward
by way of mitigation for development
across nearby sites
this park will not only provide
wonderful public walks
and views across the nearby estuary
towards woodbury
it will also provide a beautiful
landscape setting
within which housing development of
scale can be better settled
news on a decision on a district heating
network for the wider south west of
exeter site
is also expected which if approved will
allow the option of energy from waste to
heat thousands of newly built
local homes with gas boilers unable to
be fitted to new residential properties
in coming years
this in this this initiative would
provide an alternative to
electricity as a primary source for
heating
meanwhile back in newton albert members
will note
that the na1 however barton application
which is likely
which is likely to come before is likely
to come before committee for a decision
my guess would be in the new year as for
next year's priorities on slide 15
the kia the key element must be the
continued
preparation for the local plan making
good decisions in the interests
of the whole community is is also very
important
but whatever planning reforms will mean
for the structure of future decision
making
much good work has already been done via
the local plan part one
by the guest team by members and by
local stakeholders
we are well placed to go forward either
as we were
or through a new streamline process that
may allow quicker local plan making
we face enormous challenges but doing
nothing will expose us to unwarranted
and unwelcome development
while most of the new houses to be built
here are known to be bought to satisfy
local demand
there is also unlikely to be a shortage
of people either wishing to retire here
or to come here to enjoy the new normal
of the increased use
of the home as a place of work above all
we need homes not only for our sons and
daughters
but also for those least able to afford
a place of their own
i hope we can all look forward therefore
to the local plan
park ii work once it is clear what the
impending planning reforms will mean for
us
in team bridge thank you very much jim
can i thank you uh councillor taylor
that was an excellent presentation and
thank you for updating us on
the successes within your department
counselors
on the committee do you have any
questions you'd like to pose to
councillor taylor
are you gordon are you trying to raise a
hand or wave a hand or
can i in the absence of any other
questions can i ask
um counselor taylor
on top of the uh excellent presentation
that you've just given
where do you think our planning
processes at the moment aren't working
at uh satisfactorily
um i i
i think they they're working they're
working pretty well
um i think uh
it we we have issues with enforcement
at the moment which uh is which is a
struggle because
of uh with lot with lockdown what has
followed
um there is a reluctance to want to send
officers out to
two sites and um and reluctance by the
officers to go
so so there's only there's this there's
a
there is a difficulty there which i hope
i hope members will appreciate
um there is a there is a
bit of a gap showing in
increasing uh with regard to
applications in
and decisions going out um
i don't i think that is reasonable at
the moment and
as i say i hope we can with with new
recruits we can
hold the line there what's important to
note also is that
where we have decisions being made
either within eight weeks or 13 weeks
depending on whether it's a smaller
scheme or a major scheme
we are able to speak to our
two applicants um to
for extra time and that's not
necessarily because
we don't have office of time it's
because there are improvements that
can perhaps can be made to schemes
and it's very and it's quite common for
for schemes to
be batted backwards and forwards between
officers and the applicants and
as we've seen with the dawlish scheme
which
i think has been in the department for
best the best part of 12 months
that was approved uh last week on the
18th of september
a number of a number of improvements
were were made
by officers both on landscaping and on
street scenes
um which you may not notice uh first
glance but
uh the the officers do do work hard so
i'm very appreciative of uh
much more appreciative now than uh when
i'm on
if you like the inside looking out than
the other way around as it has been for
many many years um as to the as to the
good work that goes on but
as as i think one of the slides shows um
you know we can do better and we aim to
do better
thank you i think uh you're obviously
aware that you and i have had
communication from people about problems
with enforcement
i think enforcement is a major major
problem that we
we need to get our act together in terms
of
we do not appear to have the tools in
our toolbox
to be able to take the appropriate
decisions at the right time
i'll be very keen to hear how you could
work towards putting those tools into
the
toolboxes of the planners so that we
don't
get this constant deluge of people
flouting the laws
we cheer if i may we do we do have our
our offices here so if there are
specific questions you wanted to put to
offices now
now maybe a good time we have uh rose
eastman
we have fergus page on delivery and and
we have michelle luskin on
on spaceship as well so i think
i think the questions i'm asking a
general i'd rather stick to the general
in this committee as opposed to the
specifics on i'm happy to take up the
issue specifically with the officers
outside of this meeting as a as a
councillor as opposed to chair of this
committee but
i think the principle behind this is
asking how we
put in place procedures that will
support and enhance the enforcement role
which is i think the source of most of
the complaints that we get
for the council that failure to endorse
things or act on things
uh well if you're looking for further
comments i mean certainly enforcement
was an area we were hoping to
to to beef up um it's
it's it's now something where uh you
know we
know we have we have this issue uh we
also have a very pressing
[Music]
economic uh issue um so
so we are having to be very very careful
with uh with where
where resources is targeted and
obviously we have a statutory
responsibility with regard to
planning applications to to to do
to to process those um
but but certainly enforcement is high on
the list of things that
you know we would like to we would like
to do better with
that'd be wonderful perhaps the next
meeting that we have you could
update us on uh proposals or your ideas
and thoughts
how we can do that that would be very
very helpful thank you
members of committee do you have any
further questions you'd like to pose to
the council uh
there are a number of blue hands
indicating sorry
may i take blue hands and counselor
david cox
thank you chairman um uh
gary portfolio um how will neighborhood
plans be affected by the proposed
government changes to um
planning permissions um before you carry
on
david cox
yeah i note on my minute you're not
actually a member of this
committee i am i think
chair could i clarify yes uh the
managing director received an email
from um the
[Music]
leader of the liberal democrat group
advising us of a change
um so that that change has been made
with
uh councillor david cox replacing
another member in his group
so that's been done in line with the new
changes of the constitution
that would take place at the adjourned
annual council meeting
thank you in which case can ask which
councillor is no longer a member of this
group
uh councillor sheila cook
[Music]
okay my apologies then council cox thank
you
um gary how will how will government um
change proposed changes and they may not
yet come into um
to fruition or maybe change but how will
they impact on neighbourhood planning
because tim of town has spent an awful
lot of public money
has got some grants in fairness but an
awful lot of public money
a lot of time and effort has been put
into local planning
will that impact on on neighborhood
lands if we say a
site is only to have affordable housing
will that be gazumped by um
government dictat i wonder if you could
help me with that
um well that's a that's that's a lot of
question there
um there's a there's a there are some uh
other issues of course with regard to
neighbourhood plans that um that
i'm sure towns and parishes will be uh
interested to learn and and that's with
regards to sil
and whether that's going to continue
being uh offered at uh
what seals going to plan to disappear
uh sill and section 106 are going to be
combined into a new levy called the
infrastruc
simply the infrastructure the levy or
ill for short i suppose
um or nil national infrastructure
how much of that what a percentage of
that will go to the towns and
parishes i don't know hopefully it'll be
done equitably whatever
whatever whatever the answer is now in
terms of uh
neighborhood plans i'm not sure whether
they're
actually able to define uh
you know a fully affordable housing
development uh they would there would
have to be
neighborhood clans uh have have got
powers but their powers um do have to
sit within the team within the
local planned powers so if there is for
instance it's a rural community
that there are rural rural exception
sites for instance and there
there are quite strict rules in any case
as to how those
uh developments can can take place there
certainly uh you know you've heard me uh
speak in support of neighborhood plans
going forward uh and i would advise
people who are working on neighborhood
plans now
uh just as i would with our local plan
just keep going
because i think you know there's going
to be a lot of touring of throwing with
regard to
what the government are throwing at us
at the moment
and it could be that we see a much more
watered-down
set of proposals in the final analysis
that will make
little difference i i hope in many ways
they do because
there's nothing that the planning
industry the
development industry hates more than
indecision and
that's that indecision and uncertainty
is what we face at the moment
as if kobe wasn't enough so so fingers
crossed
um neighborhood plans will continue to
hold the sway that they do at the moment
thank you very much that council taylor
council doors you have a question
uh yes i i do uh and thanks for the
presentation it was very
informative unfortunately i can't share
the level of enthusiasm
that uh that you put into it and
uh and that was echoed by councillor
bulovan uh
for for me and thousands of other
residents i'm sure it would be seen as
the
madness continues uh clearly the planet
is trying to tell us something we've got
two
emergencies happening one in fast
forward one is slow motion
and the economy of the world is sliding
off a cliff in front of our very eyes
uh and in in slow motion we have the
climate change emergency
which i'm not sure we can address
through a sort of rhetoric of build
build build
um we have the roads that you you noted
the roads to nowhere internet about
which i
have driven down and my stomach churns
when i've looked at the number of trees
mature trees that have been felled uh
i've heard an awful lot about the
trees that have been planted by team
bridge i wonder if there's an already
been done
of the carbon impact of that road itself
uh i recognize this is government-led
it's not an option for t-ridge to do
nothing at all
and the numbers numbers are about to
double that they were already too high
for reasons we've tried to explain
uh been silenced trying to explain
another's kurzweil parish council were
ignored in 2012.
uh what we would like and what the
residents i'm sure would like
is for the portfolio holder and
the executive to be honest about the
future
uh rather than be enthusiastic soldiers
for government-led development
i don't think it's the doors we
shouldn't
policy we should assume that councillors
are honest
so uh i i'll ask you to
respect that the councillors are honest
i i don't think this paints an honest
position of
addressing a climate change emergency i
don't think you can cut down
thousands of mature trees uh
specifically on the stova road
and then paint that as a
net gain compared to the overall
position on tree planting
uh i i think there are an awful lot of
footages going on
however much the government want to
stimulate development i think in five
years time
we will all be looking at a very
different picture and the enthusiasm
that's been
put forward now uh i would urge the
executive
to be resetting like every person in
business
like every household in team bridge and
across the country are doing
reset your expectations
and reset what the plans are to fit the
future
that is presenting itself to us thank
you
thank you there wasn't a question there
of
cancer taylor so shall we move on then
to council parker carl
thank you um i just had two to one
question one point
um one was around um
enforcement issues and something that's
cropped up
particularly in business use is that
planning permissions when granted don't
always specify which business use
category they fall under
and that has caused issues further down
the line
so i wondered if a simple fix would just
be every planning permission that's
issued has the business use attached to
it
and it's very clear-cut and simple to
see there
one other thing in your presentation
counselor taylor
you talked about cell liability and
there was a 10 million pound difference
between 2014 and
the last figure that you gave um i'm
just wondering
around the cell liability what the
impact of that difference differences
for us as a council
thank you uh council park khan um first
of all
on business uses um
there is in part
in the consultation that closes on the
first of october i believe
uh is the changes to a number of uh
rafter business users actually a
simplification some may say
gross over simplification of uh of the
of business uses so it could be that um
a classification is given uh today
that in a in a month or two's time would
be uh
would be lumped in with something else
anyway um
but uh but that mean i'm happy to look
at specific instances
uh with you uh no problem no problem
at all um in terms of the seal liability
uh
i think it did mention something in the
slides i didn't
read it through um
let's have a look it was a comparison
with 2014
um i may be that our business manager
rose eastman would i would be able to
give you an answer today
on that or i could or i could get back
to you
if i may chair of course yes
my reading of that slide is that since
2014 we've issued liability notices of
18 million pounds
whereas this year alone that suggests
that we issued uh
still liability notices of eight million
so uh
one i believe is cumulative showing the
um
uh cumulative effect of granting
planning commissions over time and the
number of developments that are coming
on stream for us
uh whereas the other uh is uh
you know one's one year and one six
years if i'm wrong in that i'm sure
fergus will correct me but that's that's
my understanding of those figures
thank you thank you very much
sir uh council pocket calendar you happy
with
um it doesn't really clarify what i was
wanting to know
what the still liability impacts us or
is that money that we have then got to
spend on infrastructure projects and is
that a reduction we're seeing or is is
it as rising mentioned in accumulation
or
what is the impact of that difference in
figures on the council
i understand
the liability of courses
is effectively banked money from
development which is going to be spent
15 15 of it if you don't have a
neighborhood plan will be sent
will be spent uh spent locally if you've
got a neighborhood plan you get 25
of it to be spent locally the rest of it
is to be spent by the
district uh so it may just represent
a re-time tabling of cash coming forward
and certainly i think uh where we see a
reduction in uh housing completions
uh a drop off in insulin liability will
follow
similarly uh when when there are good
years there's still liability yeah
they will increase thank you
um council hook you have a question
thank you chair two or three first of
all
you you've highlighted quite rightly the
important meeting
on thursday of this week at 2 p.m
regarding the
white papers um and
my question first of all is
will the council make its decision
at that meeting about its uh
representations to government or
will that be a sort of a consultative
meeting with another meeting perhaps of
the full council
to confirm
um a response because it obviously would
carry weight if it was a council-wide
uh response affirming huge i imagine
hopefully opposition to the proposals
or at least most of the proposals
contained within the white paper as i
understand it the
you've alluded to the number of houses
and
i imagine that many had apoplexy at the
thought of the implications of that
which you outlined
so that's the first question how is the
council going to come to a
um a corporate decision as it were about
that that white paper response second
point i was shouting hallelujah when you
when you spoke about the cycleway
extensions from tinmuth
and you mentioned your electric bike
which i'm hoping to
also uh obtain because i couldn't go up
i don't think
i could quite as easily go up those
hills now as i maybe could have done a
month or two ago
or maybe even a year or two ago um
can you put a bit of flesh on on the
state of those cycleways
and were you referring to the one to
dolish or were you referring to the one
to bishop stanton because
both are important but i believe
critically for
um the economy of newton overton and
timmoth right now the one to tin with is
absolutely critical
and my third point or question
um one of your early slides whether it's
the first or second i can't honestly
recall
illustrated i think and please correct
me if i'm wrong that the number of
planning applications that had come in
had remained steady or even increased um
and it looked like there was a lot of
planning business
in the pipeline but i understand the
most
recent the network the next planning
committee has been cancelled for lack of
business
do those two statements marry up um
thank you uh uh councillor hook um
certainly the there's there's often no
direct correlation between applications
in and
the uh and what goes to committee
uh although in the grand scheme of
things uh yes there would be
um so i'm so i don't i don't really know
why there
why there's not enough business um to to
go to committee
for the the next time around um
but that's but most most applications as
i'm sure you
are are actually uh approved or refused
uh but by buying it by officers um
this is that we are we are
let's have a look so the green line on
the on the map the uh
total applications outstanding as you
can see is going up
this is represented by the blue line
versus
being greater than the red line on an
ongoing basis
so so we are slowly but surely slightly
falling behind
um but uh with as i made as the point i
made was with with the
with the staff now returning
and the recruitment process uh there is
an element of drag on the recruitment
process in that people will have to give
notice and get it ready to get people in
through the door
and warmed up but but
i do believe we will be holding the line
once once we're over this particular
lump in the carpet
in terms of the green infrastructure
and the electric bike um uh well i
hadn't bought an
electric bike yet but you'd be you'd be
welcome to borrow it but if i did
although there is one i understand for
hire sorry
available from our bike hut outside
forward house so
i'm sure i'm sure that that could be
made available should you should you
want
uh it's the teen estuary trail uh gordon
so uh
newton abbott to timothy the doris
section well i don't know perhaps
perhaps they'll whack an extra wide uh
path on the side of the sea wall and
then we'll have a nice nice flat
run through from dallas to timmoth or at
least for most of it
um in terms of thursday's meeting
uh it's um the
it's the local plan working group that
are
uh that are taking uh taking the
temperature you like
from from members about what they feel
about both consultations
uh that's the changes to the planning
system and the white paper planning for
the future
uh the the it's the the one that closes
up on the first of october is obviously
the one that uh
is focusing minds at the moment with
such a short amount of time
there's other than this meeting i don't
think we have to have another meeting
um in in september i'm not sure uh but
um i would i would
guess that the the chair and
may may wish to have a straw poll of
sorts as to
as to how members feel about uh about
the various subjects including
including the housing numbers on on the
day
um there's nobody that i've spoken to
let me put it like this
nobody i've spoken to that likes the new
calculation
okay counts are you happy with the
response
in which case can we move on then
counselor morgan you have a question
um yes the way um
we work and shop because of kobe 19 is
just changed immeasurably
um our high streets and town centres are
going to be they are at the moment very
different places i mean we're going to
have acres
of redundant office and retail space
um space that could very easily be
converted into affordable flat
starter homes um and i'm sure if i was a
remaining business i would much prefer
to have a potential customer next door
to me than
uh an empty premises um i mean we
we're gonna have to adapt we're gonna
have to accommodate these changes
are we in a position um as a council to
look into this to review this to
potentially think about this because
you know we don't we're not going to go
we can't go back to how it was with our
thriving high streets the way
the way things have happened you know
it's changed
changed forever and i think we need to
to adapt
um we've got this huge need for
affordable homes and
i can see potential space that they
could be put into uh it's been done
elsewhere in the country
it's been done in in parts of london
where they had office blocks that were
redundant and they've been turned into a
student accommodation
young people's accommodation start home
accommodation is that something we could
potentially look at here
you know we desperately need starter
homes for young people
and they like to be in town centers um
is that something we can think about uh
thank you uh councillor morgan i'm i'm
very supportive of
change of use uh in to to
uh residential eclip accommodation uh
where there where there is um
definitely a lack of sufficient business
to to
to keep the premises uh properly
occupied
certainly above uh street level
i think it's also important to have
vitality at street level so
so it's a it is a bouncing out but where
where upper floors
uh are empty i see no good reason
uh not to convert them to to residential
and the same would apply
uh where the design of the building
would be suitable
uh regarding office blocks and of course
that's exactly what's happening in
in sherborne house in in newton abbott
um would it only be that we had more
office blocks
to convert in in newton albert
we have a couple of office parks which
um
aren't quite in the town center um most
most of uh newton
doesn't have purpose-built office office
build office buildings
um the permitted development uh
changes or the extension of the
permitted development rights
allows change of use to from office
buildings
to outside conservation areas with
without planning permission alongside
extension to to these buildings
that's a bit more difficult than it
sounds because if you're going up a
given number of floors you need a lot
more strength in a building you need
fire rigs you need
a lot of things that you may need
planning permission for but you need a
lot of other permissions
uh to to get and i wouldn't want people
to get carried away
um you know sectioning off bits of
office with
uh plasterboard and you know
and uh stuffing it stuffing it full of
uh
ill cons ill-conceived um residential
premises so so there has
there has office block conversion has
had a lot of bad press
some of it justified some of it not but
the principle
of adjusting development
uh existing development it is a form of
brownfield development without ever
actually having to put a new building up
it is a sound one in my view
thank you okay council morgan yeah i i
just think it's
it will be an exciting way of
revitalizing our time centers
having people living there as the
eventual premises
true thank you right are there any
further questions for
councillor taylor please
i'm seeing no hands coming up um council
telecom thank you very very much indeed
there's an excellent uh presentation to
the uh committee and i thank you for
your time and effort that you've put in
for that
thank you very much chair pleased to be
here thank you
and move on now to um reports and
matters referred to the committee
item nine on our agenda today um is
counselor jeffrey here
i am briefly uh we haven't noticed of
the notice of motion for discussion on
our agenda today
now obviously this was also discussed at
the ons meeting this morning
would you like to just bring us up to
date with what the outcome of that
meeting was
so we don't try and repeat everything
that was said this morning
yeah i can do um so the
this notice of motion has come through
before so everybody should be quite
familiar with it
we're looking at point b on the notice
of motion
um and this morning i just gave a brief
overview
which i'll do now which is um
[Music]
going through the points of point b
which aren't numbered but um we'll go
the first one um was to work alongside
devon county council
devon county council black have actually
put forward
a very similar notice of promotion
themselves which they've accepted
um and they're going it's going through
their scrutiny committees so
i would suggest that we um continue to
liaise and work alongside them with what
they're trying to do
um somewhat working in partnership for
the whole of the county i think that
would be good
um the second point
exploring the possibility of an
education transformation
project as i informed rns1 this morning
i've progressed that somewhat with some
counsellors
and some local organizations and um
we have somebody that lives in team
bridge that is a professor
of um i don't know his full title but
he's a professor and i think somewhat
expert
in caribbean history and culture who has
put forward two of his phd students to
work with us
on developing that project at no cost to
the council
and so i'm progressing that project as a
pilot
in the first instance with timbridge
timmouth
community school and once we've
established how that works with the
schools
um and how they want to take it forward
we'll start to look at rolling that out
across the district i think so
just to let everyone know that has
progressed as things have been moving
along
um the third point was to lobby
government
and what i would say is that any
councillors
that have general support of these
points any campaigns that they feel
are worthy of looking at just to put
those forward
and for the council to look at and to
get involved in
and then the final point was in
partnership with dcc
looking at um a review of street names
and monuments
within team bridge um and that is to
look at whether
we should be putting plaques up or
whether we should be looking at
historical projects to go alongside that
um or just generally celebrating things
that have taken place
i think i've mentioned before but i've
since found out through doing some of my
research that um
sheldon bridge has historical links to
plantations
and has received um the companies
involved in building that bridge to
receive
monies um when the abolition of straight
slave trade happened and i think that's
really really interesting to know
because you can walk across that bridge
or drive across it and not know that
um so putting plaques or something like
that in place might be really
interesting
for people that are visiting the area um
so yeah so that's where we are with
everything um ons one accepted
and and have put forward um three
members
of their group and i think it was widely
accepted that um
we would look to have three members of
ons2
to support that as well thank you chair
thank you very much indeed um before we
move
on much further are there any questions
members would like to pose to nina
i'm seeing no hands going up in which
case
can i ask for three members to work with
nina
and join the other party sorry chair
there is an indicator
from councillor
sorry council parker khan yes sorry
you've come forward yeah sorry
i couldn't press the button quick enough
it was only really quickly um
it talks about in part b about changes
to the curriculum working with devon
county council
um and i'm just wondering if whether we
ought to think about a broader reach
than that because obviously devon county
won't set the curriculum except
nationally and then by local academies
so i wonder if we could broaden our
scope maybe that's what we look at as
part of a review group
as to how we might have a wider impact
and reach a broader audience
very good idea thank you perhaps that's
something the group could take on board
nina would you happy with that
yeah definitely i think that that's
definitely a way forward and
um as councillor parker khan says it is
something that's happening nationally
and there are moves to change the
curriculum nationally as well so
um and taking those things into account
so any input that we can have
um will be welcomed i think and also
we can input something that is um
addresses things that are happening
specific to our area within that as well
so to make it more for rural communities
thank you right in which case i'll ask
for you to let me know
uh members of this committee who would
like to take part
i'm looking for the three name i'm not
asking you to put your hand up now
if you drop me an email just to confirm
now um circulate the three names
to group a or group one
and uh nina uh after this meeting
we are you all happy if we do that
for you chair um if we're to set up a
uh joint spotlight review group we'll
have a proposal and second and i'll take
a roll call vote on that
just so that we're all if that's what
you're if that's what you're suggesting
that we do going forward
in that case i'll propose the uh
creation of that group we have a second
left for that i think we've got
sarah parker come second
okay i'll i'll do a roll call um
for that proposal councillor austin
[Music]
you're on your council austin because
rustin
[Music]
[Music]
i need to charge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
counselor pedreck
[Music]
sorry councillor linda pedrick sorry i
didn't hear you sorry
it's probably me thank you
councillor swain
uh councillor bulevant uh
and just to check the committee this
morning did actually agree their
membership but you're
you're happy to agree three outside of
the forum are you
well i'm happy if three people want to
put their hands up straight away but
linda
did see some hands chair yeah i saw more
than three that was a question
i've got um linda petry
sarah parker colin anybody else i caught
those
charles nettle has his hands in that
case could i suggest those three would
everybody be happy with those three
people
you're happy you i i won't unless
there's any dissent
i won't take a roll call for that is
that okay we're happy with that
everybody happy with that that's taking
us right
thank you councillor not all
council parker khan and council linda
patrick
yes thank you very much indeed i think
it will be a very worthwhile exercise uh
to be done
okay can we are you happy therefore we
move on then nina
yes thank you thank you chair thank you
everyone you're in okay
okay that's what we will do i did notice
by the way that um
counselor jackie hook has a hand raised
is there a question you wish to raise
jackie no sorry i was just putting it up
because i was going to introduce the
next item
i see in which case
i think we're moving on now to the next
item
which is the sea level rise and
shoreline
uh shoreline management planning the
benefit of the committee this is a
project that we put in place some months
ago
and what i've asked for is a brief
opening summary of where we are
there's a hell of a lot of work going on
that we obviously
are not here today to uh decide every
action that's going through but i think
everybody ought to understand what the
indications coming through are and
understand the direction of travel
so that's basically what i've asked for
us to receive today so can i hand over
to you then please um
counselor yeah thank you sure um
yeah just a quick introduction so
coastal and flood risk management falls
within my portfolio
area have been being passed over from
nina earlier
this year so it's still quite a new and
complicated topic for me
to master um and i'd like to introduce
graham smith who's our
coastal officer who many of you might
know
um i've noted the email exchange um
that's gone on about the relative impact
and importance of sea level rise versus
storm events and i'm sure um graham will
cover that in his presentation
um i've seen the slides they're really
useful really informative
so i think you'll learn a lot from them
and i'm sure graham will answer some
questions afterwards
um so over to graham thank you
thank you thank you for the resource
thank you chair good afternoon members
if i can share a screen
okay hopefully you can see a blank
introduction
uh slide i can't see anything at the
moment um
okay
right as many of you will be aware the
different councils take the lead on
different aspects across both devon
and the region this council takes the
lead on most of the strategic matters to
do with kos
and richard rainbow ruth adams and
myself we various different initiatives
on behalf of both the county but
especially on behalf of the southwest
region
hopefully this gives us the opportunity
to bring some of the best practice that
we assimilate from
our peer group in other areas back to
our own coastal and restaurant areas
in the district here um i'm going to
start
with a um quite an eye-catching
statement
from the effort committee this was in
november 19 just before
uh covert hit that coastal risk is on
the national
national risk register is second only to
pandemic flu you can recall with
nineteen perhaps so it is
um up there in the government's minds
how we deal with that
locally and nationally is still
filtering
through
this isn't clicking through however
okay hopefully that's running a little
further
as a local authority we have a multitude
of different roles
on the coast from planning only down to
the mineral watermark
economic development through to things
like marine license
consultations and of course we've got
the public
expectation that either local authority
or coastal partnership partnerships
should know the answers to most of the
questions obviously the first point of
contact
one of our main roles um and sometimes
overlooked
is that we are the lead agency for
coastal erosion the event agency
leads on coastal flooding the local
authorities be that
unitary or districts not counties
leads on eroding coasts most coastal
schemes can cover both flooding
oracle so that's why we work hand in
hand with
the environment agency they
and when we're looking at coast erosion
this is implemented through what's
called the shoreline management plan
and this council leads what's called the
south devon bossett
uh coastal authorities group and that
leaves the relevant shoreline management
plan
for our area but as always when you're
trying to manage something you need to
know what it is you've got
to find and manage you need to be able
to measure
predict better um coastal change
we also as a council host and manage the
southwest's regional coastal marching
program
which you're probably more used to
seeing branded as the pc or the plymouth
coastal observatory now we monitor a
range of different
activities we've got wave boys which are
out in the sea
measuring waves all on a live basis the
nearest one to us
is at bullish because um continually 24
7. this is the trace from storm emma a
couple years ago
where our storm threshold line is the
red line in the middle
and the waves on that particular morning
were quite in advance of it and we had
some localized damage
it is recording on a live basis those of
you that
are interested in surfing sailing
kayaking whatever
you can use it this was a take from
the wave boy results earlier this
morning and the sea
of deutsche remarkably came this one
it's also 17.3 degrees so not
not enough too bad this time of year
we've got live data and we've got
historical trends
we also commission on a southwest basis
the two sets of flakes one in
the winter which tends to be lidar which
is a
ground truthing radar giving us a very
accurate spot height
which is supplemented by true vertical
aerial photography
this is backed up on the ground by staff
members and contractors that are going
out
doing actual readings on the ground
walking with a backpack
doing various different transects up and
down a range of different beaches
and to give us some topographic surveys
more recently this has been supplemented
by our own team here operating on the
beach
at dullish using a ground
lidar a ground laser scanner which gives
us thousands of point
heights in a sort of cloud image
there's one for example of east cliff
and team bridges asset
down on the beach in uh timber so you've
got very accurate
aerial reconnaissance very accurate um
topographic
aspects and occasionally because it's
very expensive this is backed up with
bathymetric service
we this time last year were
commissioning
um this particular craft going to take a
multi-beam
survey between the nests all the way
through
to actually through to hexmuth they gave
us a really good handle on the subsea
conditions
from both the team the network rail area
and the x systems um on our doorstep
and of course there's no point in having
data unless you do something with it so
we can analyze it in traditional graph
modes
most people like to assimilate it better
when you sort of you give them a color
coded chart across time so you can track
areas that are eroding areas that are
accreting that's when the sand
is building up what you do with that
information um varies for
the applications but always you back it
up with
information that people can your
residents
your stakeholders can simulate very
quickly and there's nothing that
conveys a message easier than an aerial
picture particularly an oblique one
this is a little contemporary image of
the point at
um timothy where we were being told that
the point was eroding and it had never
been so low
keep your eye on the breakwater in the
middle shot
um about here as compared to a picture
from
40 years ago 50 years ago where you had
the same
breakwater in the 1960s and 70s being
being exposed this isn't to say that the
sand isn't low company
it's just to emphasize that the coast is
an incredibly dynamic system
and we need all our facilities to be
able to manage it properly
now climate change is a very complex
subject when it applies to the coast
it is full of a whole whole series of
risks
and different parameters they as
officers as technical officers we have
to run with
what the government uses for its funding
mechanisms and its official descriptions
this is an independent statutory body
the committee on climate change
um our previous snp was based on what
was known as the
uk cp-09 was published in 2009
the most updated one was recently
published in november
2018.
it is a complex document with some of
the appendices behind it
but basically it is to say that climate
change will
alter our coast life and what we
currently do with it is unsustainable in
the long term there are some difficult
decisions ahead for some of our
communities
and some difficult decisions ahead in
terms of some of our infrastructure
there are currently thought to be
something like half a million properties
at
closely at risk in the next 60 years or
so that will treble
interesting to see that the committing
climate change is also using some of the
graphics within the report
is doris this is the scene at coast
guard that
we're working on on or just about to
start working on currently
um it is almost certain that england
will have to adapt to
at least one meters worth of change at
some point
in the future now the report itself and
i can follow details for
those that are involved go through from
a sort of five percent scenario through
to a 95
confidence scenario this doesn't take
into affect some of the
north atlantic oscillations and doesn't
take into affect the
potential for the western ice shelf in
the antarctic
either but it is just on the observable
and trackable changes
particularly when it comes to the
nearshore and offshore
and the wave data results we have for
the uk
it is going to change it is also a
wake-up call to government
and if we wish to implement the
shoreline management plan as it stands
currently
it could cost somewhere in the region of
18 to 30 billion pounds
it was quite a large song forgetting to
find particularly in these
times so how do we go about planning for
change because adaptation particularly
locally i'll say that at the top of the
presentation
that's implemented in the first instance
instance through what's called the
shoreline management plan
and uh this council leaves of course the
south province coastal authorities group
it is um it came to members when it was
last published in 2011 and was adopted
by all of the local authorities
within the patch illustrated by the
black line in the logo
at the bottom of the screen what is new
since it was published last time
is that this will now lead directly to
the
to the development of a new planning
policy quite a
wide-ranging uh power as well which is a
coastal change management areas and
we'll come back to those in just a
minute
the stancage area is 410 which is long
we are more or less in the middle of it
it's a fantastically diverse
coastline as most of you know around
about the area here
it is one of 20 such snps
covering the cost now we've just
finished a national review
of policy units which was looking at
were they still fit for
purpose around about a fifth of the
whole hallway and that's continuing to
put public funds into the
um existing defenses were to be looked
at again
but i mean it's the ones which is like
knights invention basically leaving the
seed to do
the same thing largely this is applies
to
salt marshes to dunes and to uh natural
cooking
environments well what about an eighth
of those were due to
change um and almost half
of the management realignments where
we're making a policy change to actively
change the course now that comes before
but is usually retreating away
away from the coast um there's a lot of
those
which we need to look at again
principally because of the funding
required to deliver them
the smp has also been the change has
been
the review that has been recommended by
a suite of
national indicators and policy directors
seeing this coming down the pipe
standpoint which is led light levellers
council
undertook an internal review of our smp
that's the 400 kilometers across that
doesn't endorse it
with about 200 policy units all over
that length and
our policy units range from up the x
um along the opening calls both sides of
the scene and down and down to the top
of the boundary
the ones circled in blue are the ones
that we are technical officers wanted to
review
again as part of this process and they
were put forward as part of a national
health check which was the first stages
of this shoreline management and review
process
so the shuttle management period is a
nationally led program
by royal hospitals and jacobs working
for the ea
and the first couple of phases have been
um almost completed they're slightly
behind
where they wanted to be largely because
of um kovis
but they're just about to publish their
health check
system we are looking at a little bit of
funding coming down the
the pipe to take what has been the
national pro uh process to date
to be able to put that local flavor and
that local adoption and delivery
processes on that aspect we expect a
little bit of money from national we
expect to be
bidding for local levy to make that into
a usable process for the three
smps within the southwest region
and importantly to be able to change the
way that some of the policies
are implemented there is a new process
on being target-led rather than just
being epoch or time-based lead
and that the action plan process should
be a live document
once the smp was published it tended to
gather dust on
most most people's shelves wasn't used
useful for the
national ministers wasn't useful for us
as uh
local coastal managers either
so we are looking at a change where
there are um
both divisions of policy and also
different types of trigger to
enact change both of which will lead
through to
the shoreline management plan and this
coastal change management areas which
will be
adopted within the local planning
process
adaptation isn't straightforward um and
there will be some very difficult
choices ahead this was a local so-called
example
flagged up in in the national um uptake
most of you will be aware
of slapped and lee and the road between
dartmouth and toro cross it's not
defended
particularly well it was damaged in 2001
there wasn't any justification for
national funding to repair the roads
because
of itself it doesn't directly prevent
damage to houses or threats to life it
was just an infrastructure i say just
within the
event of commerce because it doesn't
meet the current national funding
streams
however it was repaired back in 2001.
different section of it was damaged in
2018 and again money's money were found
two and a half million pounds
um to rebuild rebuild the road even
though it was against the smp
policy this just demonstrates that um
there will always be societal political
pressures for a short-term fix which is
not necessarily
in the interest of the long-term
sustainable management we're getting
slightly more adapt
and adapt at it but we'll always be
public pressures
adaptation isn't quick or easy we reckon
there are something like
1400 kilometers of east coastline which
is not
economic to defend properly just based
on the numbers of properties
um this is in spite of the recent
government funding settlement
announcement that 5.2 billion pounds
were being put forward from 21 to 21
21 to 27 um six year period that's
both for fresh water and for um coastals
and against that frankly huge sum at 5.2
billion
um was a nice quote in the effort
committee from the national trust
that they explained it taking three
years and an awful lot of money to
persuade the key in
the community just to relocate a very
well-loved cafe that is
down there now the point of the
presentation was not to provide the
answers or even provided by the
questions
but we were asked to provide an entree
to the committee
to make members aware aware of what's
coming down down the pipe and we are
about to start the process of
re-evaluating properly
the shoreline management plan which
covers our council
area thank you chair thank you graeme
that was a super
presentation outline of the situation
we're facing
so that members are aware if you look at
the 2050
maps for flooding arising from
the change of sea levels and obviously
this debate about how much the sea level
will change
but if you look at some of the base maps
it shows on the worst case conditions
which are
spring tides when the low pressure is
overhead where the winds blowing in the
wrong direction and things like that
the whole of the centre of newton abbot
goes underwater
fourth house will be flooded the
electrical distribution center at
grinnell road will be underwater um the
hospital will be on the water
so it's important recognizing these sort
of changes that are coming through
that we understand what plans are in
place to protect
that area of town which by definition
can't be just uplifted and moved
elsewhere
um and that's the reason for asking
graham
who is at the heart of the process to
look at
and advise us about the plans that the
various people have
it's within our remit obviously to
invite contributions from
specific bodies to ask them their plans
but i think this is best done
in concert with the work that graham is
doing and it should be something that
this committee keeps a watching brief
off
on so there's something i propose that
we do moving forward
i have two questions being raised jackie
you still got your hand raised
gordon you have your hand raised as well
thank you
sorry to hone in on a detail but mindful
of the council's
financial issues of the moment and
indeed
for the next few months if not years
all this work that is done for other
authorities in conjunction with
um other authorities i'm assuming that
they all make a contribution financial
contribution
um to your work graham or to the
council's work
do all the councils covered by that
that that work contribute or is it a
government sponsored scheme whereby the
central government pay us um to do that
work
is it negotiable and have we negotiated
up the figure
of late thank you
cancer hope there are it's a mixture of
both
for the stag cage the southern dorset
coast authorities group it is a
member contribution um we are one of
about 12 members that pay in
to that it is a relatively modest fee
you get 750 pounds a year each just to
run the process
all direct works which come out of that
are part
quite like running the smp itself he's
nationally funded or is through
local levy which is a regional
allocation things like the
regional coastal monitoring program we
are we have been running this for
15 or so years into the five-year
transies
and we've recently submitted two
national a 9.2 million pound bid
which we are confident about for the
next five year tranche which starts at
the beginning of the next financial year
so the vast majority of it is nationally
funded through these regional groups
the one exception being the membership
fees
for just the the running and the
secretariat
of the coastal authorities group
so thank you great so we're not going to
pop up
we ought to be making something won't we
really we're not out of pocket anyway
we're not allowed to say that we make
anything
okay okay well i hope we are it's worth
saying everything's 100
recoverable so the coastal monitoring
programs 100 government funding
um and that's government grants so that
that covers all the costs and
officer times thank you very much indeed
council doors you have a question yeah
yes i i do and i
i was going to say i enjoyed the
presentation it was informative and
worrying
uh equally um and i've seen
the uh maps that uh look forward into
the future that that
you've mentioned share which are clearly
worrying i've also seen newton abbott on
a sunday morning when i've been out
running
uh within a few inches of being
overwhelmed i've talked to shop owners
who
told me stories of uh putting sandbags
in front of their department stores and
just
seeing off their their shops being
overwhelmed so what what i'm interested
in
and i'm maybe the answer isn't here and
now
but what what are the tools what the
metrics that would actually stop that
which
clearly the high tides linked to the
weather events
uh and also the upstream um
uh prevention that that's been built but
it could also be
the overwhelmed um given we're within a
few inches
now um what what can be done in what
period of time to
to stop what looks like an inevitable
issue
well i think uh that is the question
we're posing back to be kept informed of
that the team is working on and that's
what we want to know
this work is just starting and we look
forward to
presentations coming in to tell us and
advise us i would say at this stage what
we're looking at here is sea level
change
what we're not looking at is the impact
of climate change as it affects rainfall
and
and water coming down the lemon and the
tea or the other rivers in the area
that is a different question it hasn't
been merged with this one
it's purely sea level rise chair is it
okay to
jump in there just um so there is a
wider project looking at
newton abbot um and the fluval risks
and inherently in newton now but the
fluval and tidal and the sea level risks
are interlinked at
the lower edges where the title extent
is so there is a wider project going on
in the background with environment
agency looking
at um downstream but also upstream so
there's a lot of work going on what can
be done upstream
looking at you know various stories
mechanisms and stuff like that so
um if appropriate we'd come back at a
different different time and update you
on that work that's going on
surrounding those sort of upstream
things aside to sea level rise
i think once we've got the first
information back from work that is going
on about the coast
and the sea level change it certainly
would be very helpful and interesting to
get
a combined view of how we're going to
protect
the uh the major conditions that we have
so in due course i'll ever make that
happen
are there any other questions guys
i see no hands going up in that case
graham can i thank you for an excellent
presentation i think it touched all the
right um
right spots it raised the right issues
and certainly pointed us in the right
direction so thank you very very much
indeed for that and thank you jackie for
arranging that
right should we move on
uh in the foreign it's um proposed that
the committee
uh notes the report so i should have a
proposal and second
and um to take a very quick roll call
for that
when i take it that we note the report
can we do it through a show of hands or
do you need to go through it yeah
if there's no dissent any
no dissent are there any any dissenting
voices
no i see
does anybody wish to take a break we've
got one more item on the agenda
in that case we'll go straight through
to the performance monitoring
information a report
which you all had as a separate item
within your portfolio
have you i think you've all had a chance
to read the notes this is the revised
reporting structure that came forward at
the last meeting by the way
where it purely focuses the attention of
people towards those areas where there
are issues or problems
and within our group we've got
a number of areas which are amber
if i can refer you to page seven
which is part of the going to town
caution and
there's a caution in terms of the
provision of
broadband now the explanation is given
on both
i think we're reasonably in terms of the
fact that they're obviously affected by
kobe
so unless there's specific questions
anybody wishes to ask about those two
areas i'll move on to the final one
the final section is on page 11 i would
like to draw your attention to which is
a red
caution and a question please
do we have um somebody who can tell us
who owns
cue this particular one item 10 viable
uh visible council the pi code is c
s double v i 1 4
which is about the novice descriptions
to
my account this is the people using the
computer system to transact business
with team bridge
do you have anybody here representing
that it doesn't tell me
which is the ph responsible for it
through your chair we have a officer
here um who
who may be able to shed some light on
this uh
please okay um
this whole area vital viable council um
sits
under a strategic jet direction and
corporate
resources uh executive member area
however the whole strategy
is cross-cutting and this relates
particularly
to people signing up to have an online
account to do business with the council
so this one may be better placed with
one of the other
executive members it's difficult to
assign
to such a broad area of the the strategy
one particular person so this could be
counselling with me for example
[Music]
i think we need to allocate these
specifically to any to a member of the
executive so that uh they can go on
the one particular one which are there
are two issues down here where we have
reds
one i'm particularly concerned with is
the one which is
customer complaints dealt with in within
20 days
which is now fallen below 70 percent
now one appreciates that during covet
there's been a demand on our resources
however
what we've seen in that time is a
greater incidence of people issuing or
being forced to use the computer to
integrate or to interact with the
council
and to see the level of performance fall
off
to the level at which it shows here
given that back in march
12 months ago the performance is just
under 90 percent
last march it fell to 72 percent now
we're down to 69 percent and the same
reason for it falling down
would put forward in march we put
forward today
the system failures caused it
and i think this is something that goes
to the heart of the effective
council management and shows
how effective the council is being at
looking after the interests of its
um council taxpayers perhaps i could
hope chairman
yes please you would if you would ellen
thank you thank you very much um in
terms of uh
assignment of portfolios uh i'm always
very happy
if you scrutiny are concerned if you
flag these up with me
and we'll make a note after the meeting
but um in terms of the my accounts
uh my first preference with that that
would probably sit with uh
councillor wrigley in terms of i.t i'm
grateful
is the question of uh how we handle
complaints sir because it's part of the
aurelian overhaul of the council's
approach
to complaint handling which i've been
speaking with the managing director
about so you're at the
very early stages of this
at the if when people have gone all the
way through the council's process as you
know and colleagues know
they could actually then pass on their
complaint to the local government
ombudsman
and i've been concerned that perhaps uh
councillors don't see
the outcomes of that in council to see
if there's any pattern whether one-offs
i mean we're talking about a very small
number in that sense
um so those reports of the ombudsman
uh and the reports will be going toward
it scrutiny to review at that top end
though you'll agree that
those are the small handful complaints
that get that far
by far and away the biggest number of
comments concerns complaints
i've dealt with through the council's
complaints procedure and again
i think scrutiny should be looking at
them in terms of are there any lessons
learned so
from my experience in the national
health service the boards of a trust
would be looking at their
complaints not in the detail but in the
lessons learned
you know so very often it might be that
a you know
someone feels they've been spoken too
badly the information
the leaflet wasn't good enough at a very
simple level
but nonetheless the board would be aware
of that and would be told what is being
done to address
and pick up on these comments and i
think um that over
in scrutiny should be seeing that as
should the executive
now we do need to get behind why there's
been a drop in the performance as
has been reported to you i suspect to
some extent that has been around
stuff being followed and the period of
covered
and so what we'll do is arrange for the
next meeting for us to look in more
detail behind that
and get back to members about some of
the detail behind that picture
and then what's being done around it and
also how we're going to set
out in future to ensure that members of
overview and scrutiny
if you like see the bigger picture on
complaints so not just
what percentages are dealt with in time
but are there lessons that are being
learned so
uh not you know is there one particular
department that seems to be getting more
complaints proportionally than others
and if so why is that does it relate to
a particular
type of service within that function so
chairman i hope that's helpful i really
do appreciate what you've said i think
you're at the very
early stages of the overview which the
executive and i
already put in hand and i'm grateful for
the opportunity to
get some more clarity around that thank
you thank you i accept your offer to
come back at a future meeting and
give us some more information one that i
agree with you is the need to be able to
identify root causes within
any complaints process you know it's one
thing if you get
a thousand complaints which are all
different but it's totally different if
you get 990 complaints about the same
thing
and 10 little ones so it would be very
helpful to get these broken down into
areas of responsibility
so it would highlight the areas where we
need to focus
focus attention but certainly i'm happy
to take uh
feedback at a future meeting from you
and thank you for offering to do that
are there any other questions anybody
wish you to ask about
the performance reports counselor parker
khan
thank you it was just around um the
subscriptions to the my account
um element of the council and obviously
we've been um
most of the promotional work done by
communications has been concentrated on
kovind 19
and and can really accept that have we
got a long term strategy now to
to ramp up um the promotion of the my
account service
i think that's something again we can
pass back to alan connect and ask
the leader comes back in a future date
he gives us a plan well we'll certainly
get back to you
i have an account and um you know i hope
all members of the committee have an
account and if you haven't it's very
easy to set up certainly help
but yes you're quite right and i do
appreciate the question from
councillor parker khan so we'll come
back on that about what the trajectory
is how far we've gone
and where we're aiming so thank you very
much
thank you very much indeed for your time
are there any other questions that uh
councils have that we used to put to the
members of the executive
in which case we should move on with the
agenda nobody's raised
okay
[Music]
was there a question counselor conor
in which case no no there wasn't i was
indicating to speak earlier and then you
called me chairman i'll just
get you to take my hand down my side
thank you sorry
thank you for doing that can i therefore
just ask you to note the
future report if there is any project or
work that you would like or think we
ought to be looking at can you please
make use of the form that's contained
within the
um within the pack and give it a
required
level of information for us to work on
are there any other questions
are there any issues that you think we
haven't touched
count well sorry sarah do you want it
yeah through you
just to check that all members are in
agreement to note the report to save me
doing a roll call
all happy no descent
thank you receiving those descent
okay all happy in which case
i think it's tea time can i thank you
all for attending and i
look forward to uh seeing you at the
next meeting
thank you very much yes
thank you chairman thank you kevin
thank you coming